that's funny that's that's a funny
character sitcom not cool cooler it's
like number one for like two years in a
row the guy guest stars it goes down
yeah he does like modern family next
week no numbers well I might get hired
on that but they didn't they didn't they
didn't pick me on this one role and I'm
saying do you know how much the money
these [ __ ] guys made oh oh they set
for life right life syndicated D a week
for three like $1,000 a week but here's
the thing about that what you know what
and he's a broken man yeah I know what
he said while he was on this podcast
what'd he say he said that in the comedy
world he he doesn't feel like he fits in
with your you guys yeah well he doesn't
and that's not a thing against him yeah
because he's not a [ __ ] stand up I
know but he feels he wants to be where
you are from the cool kid yeah he may
want that like the thing is he will not
get it but the thing is is that but
that's the point you're never happy
where you are mmm-ah
yeah I think there's some truth to there
because wherever you are it kind of
excludes those other spaces like in
other words if my path had been a huge
sitcom star I wouldn't be at the store I
don't think I I don't think yeah you'd
be too busy Maron that's kind of a
perfect career right now I mean like
he's got the podcast he's got the cool
the aspect now he's got Club you know
what I mean it seems to be like almost a
perfect little Curry's doing it it you
know everything he's done that does make
sense to his world though yeah it's not
as if he's like you know the next
Captain America you know but I was told
- that likes even someone like Clooney
we'll hear that
else gotta leave in a big movie and
he'll be like no I mean God I mean I've
heard [ __ ] like that like no matter that
human nature maybe it's just human
nature human nature so you do a Nestle
commercial yeah I don't really do it was
a coffee drink mate Wow it's just it's
crazy yeah just do twenty million movies
doesn't dude think about the residuals
like I'm happy as [ __ ] when I get 1,100
yeah yeah yeah these guys get like
quarterly yeah their residuals are just
insane I mean they can buy a house with
the residuals yes a residual yeah yeah
they're like [ __ ] making so much
banking they've got to go do that yeah
it's like nah they're sellout shit's
they realize specially Samuel Jackson
who I hear his movies combined are the
biggest grossing movies ever like he's
the biggest movie star money-wise Wow
Wow
all time of all time all time yeah and
he's what's your and what I love is that
he's still like kind of a tough guy like
what's your wallet how about what's in
your [ __ ] wallet that's my question
you [ __ ] your wallet and why you [ __ ]
asking me what's in my while you trying
to embarrass me that's why it's steve-o
when I did that okay so when Steven oh
oh and I did some sort of Billboard
Awards but we're presenters for some
[ __ ] [ __ ] right back in Vegas
back in the day and steve-o was drinking
at the time and he was a my co-host hmm
like co-presenter this was a billboard
award something some [ __ ] award show
and Samuel Jackson was the host of it oh
he was right and so we rehearse all
steve-o's drunk and we're going to the
podium to do our thing and Samuel
Jackson's over there and steve-o just
starts going you [ __ ] shout Jackson
James face you face Jesus you're doing
this
like he was saying it and thence annual
dinner whoa I'm sweaty and you're doing
you know you're doing the Billboard
together hosting this yeah whatever
right and then he ran backstage squeezed
a woman oh yes squeezed a woman in the
butt
he got banned from the MGM Grand for a
lot of my job yeah
did Jackson respond to you no he didn't
he just pretended he didn't hear it but
I was there yeah my point though is is
that I just I don't know see that
happened oh I remember the point
[Music]